AND IT IS OFFICIALHEELER WITH AC
ASSIST AND THE SHOT AND SCORE
OFF THE SHOT, HE PUTS IT TO AN
ANOTHER PENALTY COMING IN FRONT
AND WOLL IS DOWN.
AND HE WILL HANG ON CREATE
A CHANGEOVER ON ENTRY.
>> Dennis: EHLERS WITH A QUICK
WRIST
AND THEN HELLEBUYCK WILL SMOTHER
IT. ANGLE.
LOWRY TO THE NEAR SIDE BOARDS.
PLAY.
AND THE LEAF HAVES TIED THIS
HAT SHELDON
KEEFE REALLY TRUSTS. SHE NET.
AN SANDIN.
THAT IS IN IS EHLERS!
GOES HIGH SHORT SIDE.
AND WOLL GOT ENOUGH OF IT.
D
LOGAN STANLEY AND
EVGENY SVECHNIKOV,
BUT WILL GET A DIFFERENT
MATCHUP.
A LITTLE TIGHT
AND HE CHIPS IT ON.
THERE WAS NO DOUBT IN KYLE
CONNOR'S MIND IN MISTAKEN, KYLER
MAY HAVE EVEN FOOLED HIM BY JOS!
SCHEIFELE SENDS THE CAPTAIN IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE ICE.
CENTRED INTO THE SPOT.
MATTHEWS WITH THE SHOT.
SAVE MADE HELLEBUYCK..
OVER THE ELBOW, THE EAR OF
HELLEBUYCK.
AUSTON MATTHEWS HAD SEVEN KASE E
PAST CONNOR HELLEBUYCK.
AND IT'S A TWO-GOAL GAME.
FOR A REBOUND HOPING FOR A
LOWR.
GOOD BACK HOLL OR
HOLL AND NOW A LONG SHOTOF THE .
NYLANDER ANOTHER SHOT.
SAVE
END TO END THEY GO.
SANDIN WALKS IT N SAVE MADE
HE
AND THE JETS HAVE AFTER 6-3 LEAD
IN
SCHEIFELE.
DOESN'T BREAK STRIDE.
AND SCHEIFELE GOES UP AND OVER
THE BLOCKER.
A POWER PLA